si ça c'est pas un crime passionnel
avant qu'on commence je tenais
tu es là
vous présenter toutes mes condoléances
j'adore cette cuisine
[Musique]
tu crois que Tom devrait gérer la faire
oui pourquoi son passé pour rire
l'attention
je vous connais vous savez vous savez
quoi on est né le même jour
vous pensez que je l'ai tué pour
l'instant on exclut aucun suspect
omie rétudi vous avez la belle fille ici
dans cet en avenir tu pourras pas être
flic toute ta vie
avec la médaille tu reçois 20 000
dollars je peux savoir ce qui se passe
au juste
ils veulent sauter de donner
très franchement
[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une seule chose que j'aime
quasiment autant que je t'aime toi
on peut pas dire qu'il me le rende bien
[Musique]